welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and did you see the world's first
look at marvel's mark spector spectacle
on disneyplus.com i did and good lord i
never thought i'd be happy to see oscar
isaac violently beat a stranger's meat
in a public restroom in the name of
religion because that's exactly what he
does in our first look at mood night for
marvel studios but just who is this mark
spectre guy anyway and why has he
historically been a moon of many faces
in the marvel comics well let's go ahead
and dive into it my nerd babies moon
knight is of course former mercenary
mark spector and also a cab driver jake
lockley and also millionaire steve grant
no he's not trying to avoid baby mama
drama mark spector just suffers from an
illness called dissociative identity
disorder or d.i.d a disorder that kicked
into high gear when his childhood rabbi
turned out to be a you know racist
killer of jews a former nazi which i'm
assuming immediately got him a one-star
review on rapemyraby.com that was not
very lahaim of you dude and this
disorder would eventually lead to the
creations of spectre's jake lockley and
steven grant personalities but before he
partied with personalities mark would
take his ass to the marines and
unfortunately become a different type of
moon night when his illness caused him
to zone out and moon marines at night um
completely just went buck naked multiple
times and then he ran away before being
dishonorably discharged which is you
know a bummer because
he is sick and then after lending his
services to the cia for a little bit he
would eventually end up becoming a gun
for hire and meeting up with his future
bff for life frenchie duchamp during his
time doing sketchy with bullets for
money because that's basically what
being a mercenary is and eventually
doing sketchy mercenary would find
frenchie piloting mark to the border of
north sudan and egypt to do some good
old-fashioned angelina jolie brand tomb
raiding at the suggestion of this crazy
dude named raoul bushman another
mercenary from the fictional african
nation of virunda and when i say this
dude is crazy i mean like tattoo a white
skull on your black face because you
want to see the fear in your victims
eyes before you kill them type of crazy
which is you know very similar to
walmart crazy but still somehow not as
scary but needless to say mark and
french they quickly realized that they
made a huge mistake by giving this
maniac bushmen more than five minutes of
their time but mark would ultimately
regret it the most when buschmann beats
his ass and then leads him to die in the
desert you know after mark dared to show
outrage for bushman's murder of innocent
civilians including the archaeologist's
father of marlene aleran while the two
of them were in egypt looking for cool
sandy old stuff in the tomb of the
ancient pharaoh seti and mark spector in
dire need of a blue gatorade would
eventually trek his dehydrated ass
across the african desert all the way to
that very same tomb of seti and collapse
in front of the statue in that tomb
called the statue of konchu the egyptian
god of the moon and vengeance but
however when mark was about to draw his
very last breath conscious himself the
blue gatorade of moon power and save his
life by transforming mark spector into
conscious mortal fist of revenge on
earth the moon knight and then after
this mark would go on to start a romance
with marlene and go on to fight evil in
conscious holy name with frenchie as his
pilot in the chair guarding the
innocents who walked the night in the
most brutal of fashions with bushman a
character called the sun king and mark's
own brother randall spector as shadow
knight as his three you know main
nemesis amongst others okay get this
you're planning a vacation hmm this
morris island looks nice ancient temples
beautiful scenery but wait those aren't
vacationers those are deadly warriors if
you like combat games and want to check
out a really good one head to morris
island with the thrilling combat game
naraka bladepoint it's on sale for 30
off right now naraka bladepoint is an up
to 60 player mythical action combat game
with martial arts influenced melee
combat inspired by the legends of the
far east it's got gravity defying moves
giant arsenals of weapons and
customizable heroes with really cool
abilities and naraka has a variety of
game modes including solo trio and
bloodsport to satisfy team players and
lovers of 1v1 fighting and you can run
the raqqa on a low end or basic spec pc
and they just introduce a new hero you a
sean the unyielding and he's got this
really well designed heavy armor because
he's a general and he has a powerful
skill set to bum rush enemies and knock
them over and he's the second hero in
the game with the special ability to
make himself bigger and stronger like a
titan which god i wish i could do that
just make myself bigger and stronger but
i need to go to the gym so play uh sean
and the other awesome warriors of noraka
playpoint by clicking the link in this
video's description to get the game
before november 17th for 30 off which is
pretty great naraka playpoint go stab
some dudes let's do it man people love
to compare moon knight with other you
know certain nights of nighttime
vengeance and with you know good reason
considering that moon knight knows
several forms of martial arts like
karate savate and judo and even throws
crescent-shaped darts at enemies you
know much like certain batman are prone
to do i've personally have yet to see
batman rip his arch nemesis face off
because that is literally what mark ends
up doing to bushman because that guy and
the face that his tattoo wrote on to be
quite honest he's a murderer he's a
killer i hope his face rots in hell like
avatar of the god of vengeance isn't
just something mark puts on his linkedin
profile page alright like marky mark
leaves the marks like not only does he
use his trusty truncheon to beat people
up regular baton or nunchuck style he
also uses it to grapple away from the
scene of the beating so nobody would
know it was moon night but hey actually
that's not true because you'd honestly
be lucky if blunt force trauma was the
most of your concerns because moon
knight has been known to beat the barely
living moonlight out of his victims with
sharp ass silver cestus knuckles and
even carve moon crescents into the
foreheads of his enemies because he's
crazy he's literally insane but you know
back to mark spectre's mental health
because right after mark was blessed by
conscious he would develop the
personality of jake lockley a cab driver
who knew all the goings-on of the
streets and stephen grant an incredibly
smart and wealthy money investor a
personality that would eventually lead
market to becoming a multi-millionaire
which is great for moneybags mark
because moonerangs clorox and therapy
don't grow on trees i'm just kidding
mark doesn't go to therapy
[Laughter]
but here's the interesting and
frustratingly mysterious thing about the
character of moon knight even after the
nearly 50 years since moon knight tried
to kill a werewolf during his marvel
debut in werewolf by night number 32 it
is still not 100 clear to what extent
mark spector sees and hears the moon god
crunchy and has been affected by kanchu
in general because you know due to his
illness mark tends to see and hear
things that aren't exactly there to the
point where he completely hallucinated a
team up with cap spidey and wolverine
one time like he literally thought all
three of them were there but he was just
pretending to be all three like konshu
the god is definitely real because he's
healed in a resurrected mark way too
many times for him not to be real and
even at times he's given mark crazily
increased strength depending on the
phase of the moon allowing mark to even
bench up to two tons at a full moon but
it seems that marvel has left whether or
not kanchu is the exact root of mark's
advanced mental decline purposely up in
the air to add to the mystery and entry
of their character which you know it
works because he's definitely a lot
different than batman i'll tell you that
but that is the character of moon knight
in the marvel comics in a nutshell what
do you guys think of marvel's moon
knight do you guys think that he'll be
cosmically powered by the moon like he
is in the comics for a little bit let us
know in the comment section below my
nerd babies and also of course please be
sure to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so
you can get cool shorts like this and
other nerd inspired shirts but more
importantly please follow new rockstars
wherever we are on the internet and on
youtube if you do on youtube make sure
to hit that notification bell so you can
get notifications every time we upload a
new video but as always thank you guys
so much for watching the rockstars i
love you guys so much and i'll see you
guys next time bye
[Music]
you